Рівень летальності вважається ключовим показником,
коли йдеться про те, наскільки ефективно та чи інша країна
протистоїть пандемії коронавірусу.
Ось як ситуація виглядає нині у різних країнах Європи.
Чому ж у порівнянні з іншими державами
у Німеччині помирає значно менше інфікованих коронавірусом?
Ось головні ймовірні причини:
Окрім вчасного діагностування та відповідного лікування,
тестування є вирішальним для визначення поширеності вірусу.
Німецькі відомства з охорони здоров'я кажуть,
, що почали доволі рано тестувати людей -
навіть з менш вираженими симптомами.
Тобто на відміну від інших країн, у німецькій статистиці
проходять не лише важкохворі, але й люди з відносно легким перебігом хвороби.
У Німеччині від самого початку порівняно багато тестували.
Тому ми виявляємо коронавірус доволі рано.
Таким чином ми виявляємо й дуже багато легких випадків,
які за інших умов, може, й не помітили б...
Крім того, в Німеччині наразі захворіли ще не так багато літніх людей.
Це теж факт, який відображається у статистиці смертей та вікових меж.
Нині не всі країни тестують однаково.
Відмінності між підходами країн можуть впливати
і на відмінності в показниках летальності.
Наприклад, показники Італії чи Іспанії
могли би бути нижчими,
якби тестували ширший зріз населення.
Я доволі впевнений, що коли ми оцінюватимемо розвиток інфекції в ретроспективі,
в інших країнах теж виявляться значно нижчі показники летальності
відносно кількості випадків інфікованих.
Адже тоді порахують і легкі, і симптоматичні перебіги хвороби,
і це, звісно, вплине на показник летальності.
Намагаючись якомога швидше дати відсіч коронавірусу,
європейські країни стартували з різними передумовами.
Згідно з даними Організації економічного співробітництва та розвитку,
Німеччина має 6 ліжко-місць інтенсивної терапії на 1000 населення,
Франція натомість – лише 3,1,
Італія – 2,6, а Великобританія – 2,1.
Загалом Німеччина має близько 28 тисяч ліжок в інтенсивній терапії,
тобто майже в два з половиною рази більше, ніж Італія.
Ймовірно, це надає Німеччині перевагу, коли йдеться
про лікування особливо важких випадків COVID-19.
Звісно, величезна відмінність нині в тому,
що якщо брати певні регіони Італії, Іспанії чи Франції,
то система охорони здоров'я там не працює як слід.
Тому лікарям і доводиться вирішувати,
кого підключати до апарату штучного дихання, а кого - ні.
А це, вочевидь, потім різко підвищує кількість людей, які помирають.
Німеччина ж наразі ще не вичерпала своїх можливостей.
Щодо швидкості спалаху прийнято вважати,
що в Італії вірус поширився швидше, ніж в інших європейських країнах.
Не виключено - що через туризм
та тісні економічні зв'язки
текстильних підприємств на півночі Італії з Китаєм.
В Італії значне поширення хвороби зафіксували на два тижні раніше, ніж у Німеччині.
Тобто вірус мав більше часу на поширення і охопив більше людей,
спричинивши важкий перебіг захворювання.
Італія, особливо Північна Італія має тісні економічні зв'язки з Китаєм.
Тож, я цілком можу собі уявити,
що навіть якщо в цілому
цілому кількість польотів, зокрема прямих рейсів
з Китаєм, швидко скоротили до нуля,
активний обмін між людьми
все одно відбувався далі,
що зрештою й зумовило спалах
і швидке поширення вірусу саме там.
Тим часом у Німеччині патоген виявили на відносно ранній стадії,
і, ймовірно, він передався здебільшого особам з менш вразливої групи населення.
За даними Інституту Роберта Коха, у той час як середній вік підтверджених випадків
інфікування в Італії – близько 63 років,
середній вік хворих у Німеччині – 47 років.
Експерти припускають, що багато з ранніх випадків у Німеччині
походили від тих, хто побував на лижному відпочинку в Італії та Австрії.
Гадаю, саме звідти дуже багато хто привіз вірус,
тому в цілому в нас, ймовірно, дещо вища частка молодих людей.
Дійсно левова частка тих, кого ми тестуємо,
- у віці від 35 до 59 років.
Дехто припускає, що високий показник летальності в Італії
пов'язаний з вищим відсотком інфікованих людей старшого віку.
Адже вірус, схоже, несе більше загрозу летальності саме літнім пацієнтам.
А масове поширення серед населення похилого віку
може бути пов'язане з нормами життя.
За даними ООН, в Італії кілька поколінь
частіше живуть під одним дахом, ніж у Німеччині.
27 відсотків італійців, яким за 60,
живуть разом з дітьми.
Це у 4,5 раза більше, ніж у ФРН.
Чим би це не пояснювалося - високі показники тестування,
добрі можливості системи охорони здоров'я,
часові рамки спалаху вірусу чи культурні відмінності,
які уповільнили поширення коронавірусу серед старших людей -
фактом є те, що показник летальності від COVID-19
у Німеччині наразі залишається відносно низьким.
Експерти, однак, наголошують: епідемія ще далеко не завершилася,
а дані про кількість випадків захворювання все ще неповні.